[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN POIESZ: I'm Ben Poiesz.
I'm the product manager
for Android framework.
I like how everybody's
right over there.
I wish I could join you.
The sun's going to
come and get me.
What I want to talk
to you guys about
is background limits and a
lot of the infrastructure
that we've put in place in O.
And it is a starting point.
And I wanted to try
and have this talk,
give you a glimpse as to how
we're approaching the problem
and so you don't
just think we're
trying to ruin all the
apps and everything
you're doing the background.
We're actually trying to find
a balance of enabling users
to have battery life
they can rely on
and enabling developers to
do the use cases that they
think are great and that
users respond positively to.
And so to do that,
we're going to talk
a little bit about the past,
a lot about the present,
and then a bit about
the future where,
for one of the few
times, we're going
to give you a
glimpse of the space
that we're trying
to go longer term.
So in the past, we
have Doze and Standby.
Doze and Doze Lite were
introduced to try and save
battery in two main
conditions, one
being when the device is off
for a long period of time.
So a good example of
this is I take my tablet.
I toss it in my desk, and it
sits there for a few days.
And that, you really want the
device to last a long time.
And Doze was introduced to make
that device last up to a week.
And it was largely successful
when it was introduced.
Doze Lite was trying to
take that same concept
and apply that to my
phone is in my pocket.
It's not on, but it is on me.
And Doze wasn't
identifying that situation.
And Doze Lite was
trying to target that.
And it starts slowing
down applications
and limiting what's
happening throughout the day.
And app Standby was
very similar in concept,
but had been about is
the user interacting
with the application very often?
And if not, begin
throttling that back.
We also looked at
broadcast removal.
And this was when we
targeted an initial set
of three particular broadcasts.
And the best example of
this was we were finding--
you take a photo, and
suddenly all the applications
are getting really
excited about that photo
because they're listening
to that broadcast.
And they would all be
waking up and going,
what's going on with the photo?
Is there a restaurant nearby?
Should I back it up?
What should happen?
And the user's going, I'm really
just trying to take a photo.
Like, god forbid
you're trying to take
two photos, because the first
photo triggered everybody
to wake up, and the
second photo is now
this resource contention.
And so we found this was really
successful to pull these guys
back from being these general
broadcasts, and instead,
being a bit more targeted.
And so that's kind of the
lead-in to then the present,
where we started looking
at then a general strategy
for background limits.
I'll also talk
about Alert Window,
as well, which has a very
similar problem space,
and then a bit about
how we're trying
to bring a data-based
approach to improving
system health on Android.
I don't mean health
like my personal health,
but more like the device health.
And then I'll pepper
in a few best practices
as we go through.
So background limits, why?
So what we're trying
to do is two parts.
One is to save battery.
This one was largely
around the limits
that we put in
place for location.
And the goal that
we're trying to get at
is we want multi-day
battery life.
That's what it's going to
take us a while to get there.
But that's where
we're trying to go.
And to do that, we know we have
a pretty large task in terms
of what's happening
in the background.
It's a nearly 6% to 8%
efficiency improvement
from where we are today.
And so that's like the
backdrop, if you will,
of how we're thinking about it.
And these are the
initial steps in setting
the framework for how
we're going to get there.
The other part is
about RAM management
and working on how broadcasts
are being fired to applications
and also dealing
with how applications
are running in the background
with long-running services.
So just to give you a
concrete example of this
is you have this chart
of screen-off performance
over time.
And the one thing you
can see up there--
I can't see my monitors anymore.
The sun has totally
killed me up here.
But the one thing
you can see up there
is over time,
you're going to have
a slide of your screen-off
battery performance
the longer the phone
is in the field.
You'll also see that the jank
rates, or slow UI frames,
get higher the longer the
device is in the field.
And so these are
things that we really
want to help remedy and add
robustness into the platform
so we can really
smooth these out.
Obviously, over
time devices age,
and physics comes into play,
and the march of time happens.
But we really don't want them
to be anywhere near that steep.
Another example of this is as
a device is on, in the course
of even days-- this one's
measured all initially hours
and then in days--
you can see just uptime starts
to take a toll on the device.
And so these are the things
that we're really trying
to target and to improve.
So let's dig in a little
bit to some of the changes
that we're introducing.
Background limits
on the Save RAM part
is we want to restrict
services and broadcasts.
And we want to reduce
the amount of churn
that's happening on the device.
And the Save Battery,
we're looking
to improve background location
scan rates and Wi-Fi scan rates
and to reduce them and make
them be more of a trickle
than these really bursty
events that we're seeing
happening in the ecosystem.
So for background
limits, the big one
here is we want to
reduce that RAM usage.
And to do that is--
well, that slide like the same.
I should just skip.
So how we're doing that is
with broadcast receivers.
By pulling these guys back,
you're able to then say, OK.
Oh, all these
broadcasts before that
were implicit in
waking up applications
are going to be silenced.
If you're running at the moment,
you're still going to get them.
But if you're not
currently running,
we're not going to wake you up
for them, except in the case
where they're explicit.
And explicit ones, we say
something really important
has happened, or
you've been targeted,
or you've registered
for some wake up.
And those things will still
work completely as normal
as they did before.
And so that follows like
alarms and notifications.
Other ones that we're
still keeping around--
BOOT_COMPLETED, LOCALE_CHANGING.
And these are really
events that are not
happening as the user is
trying to do something else.
And that's really
been a target of how
we approach which things
should continue to work
and which things should
we start deferring.
The other one here is free
running background services
should no longer be a thing.
And the idea behind
that is we want
users to have
visibility to what's
happening on their phone.
And so if an application
is doing something really
expensive in the
background, we want
there to be some
awareness for the user.
We don't want the device to be
toiling away in the background
without any awareness.
This also means we
want to then start
stopping those
services after they're
running for a little bit.
We're going to start
throwing an exception
if you start a background
service when you're not
in the foreground or when
you don't have a foreground
service running.
And this is also
the very last one
is we're start releasing
wake locks under some more
conditions.
You still want to
manage your wake locks.
Don't think the OS is
going to handle it for you.
But we are adding
more protections
in different scenarios where
they might have been leaked
or the developer was a
little lax in their cleanup.
We still have the white listing
strategy that we've had before.
So there will still
be a white listing
strategy that is around.
When GCM fires off a
broadcast to your application,
you'll still get woken up.
You'll get a short exemption
to handle that message.
From there, you can
kick off a service.
You could bring your
applications to the foreground
if it's appropriate.
Or you can just take a note,
run it, schedule a job or alarm
and have it be scheduled by the
OS and happen when it happens.
There's also the
flexibility, still, for OEMs
if you're relying on
some OEM-specific intent
or something behavior that's not
built into AOSP, Android Open
Source.
The OEM will be able
to define on their own
which things are explicit, which
things are implicit and should
still be fired, and which things
are implicit and should still
get the brakes tapped on them.
So you might be thinking
at this point, this all--
I guess, the user
part of my brain
is really happy, probably.
The developer side
is going, wait.
I have things to do.
I have things to say.
How can I communicate
to the developer?
It's really important, Ben.
What are you doing?
And so there's a
number of strategies,
and I'll talk about
them right now
of how to do these
operations still
with the user on a
timely basis and still
be respectful of the
battery, but then
also be able to tell
the user, no, I'm
doing something
incredibly important.
So the first one to look at is
using Firebase in Google Cloud
Messaging and using
the high-priority and
normal-priority messages I hope
your takeaway from this slide
is not fire all torpedoes
at high priority.
We really want you to be
kind of balanced and saying
if something is important, like,
say, my fire alarm is going off
at home, and I want to send
a notification to the user,
use a high-priority
notification.
It's kind of a big deal.
If you're, say, using a, oh, the
user's scheduled for a TV show
that they like, and that
TV show is now available,
and they can stream
it at their leisure,
use a normal-priority
notification.
And it'll make a big
difference in the battery
life of the device.
And it really adds
up when the ecosystem
starts taking these approaches.
The other one here
is something new.
It's called the Job
Intense Service.
And this is coming out.
We just missed the
window, but I still
wanted to talk about it for what
came out with the new 26 beta.
But it will be coming out
shortly before O launch.
And it's a strategy of you can
use Job Intense Service on O
to give you backwards
compat support
so that you will use then
Jobs when you're on O.
And you'll have an
automatic fallback
to using services pre-O.
The really nice part about this
when you have that fallback
is we'll handle the
wake locks for you.
So you don't have to worry about
are you going to make a leak
or make a mistake there.
So definitely take a look
at this when it comes out.
It's going to make your
lives a lot easier to adopt.
The other one here is
about alarms, syncs,
and job scheduling.
These are all good strategies
to run Jobs on a cadence
in the background that gives
the OS flexibility about when
it runs.
So as easy an example,
if all these applications
before when we had a world of
these broadcasts being fired,
and then applications
could start services,
they'll all start
at the same time.
And the OS really has only
nukes to deal with this problem.
We can only kill your process.
There's no ability to throttle.
We can't try to squish RAM.
It's just you live or you die.
And when the RAM
becomes contentious,
we start thrashing
pretty rapidly.
When you're using
Jobs and Alarms,
the OS has now
flexibility to defer,
to run one job at a time,
a few times at a time,
and spread it out across
the lifetime of the device.
And that avoids then
resource contention.
It avoids janky UI
in the foreground
because stuff is happening
in the background.
So I've made this really
exciting flowchart for you
that you can look at later.
But the idea behind
it is roughly
looking at what are the
different stages that
are happening and what is
the right choice for you
as a developer and for the
user to have that be the best,
most efficient experience
for the use case
that you're trying to achieve.
Yes, the end of this is
maybe you shouldn't do it
in the background.
And that's the one I really want
you to focus on is think about
do I really have
to be doing this?
Is the user going to understand
what I'm trying to do?
If the user is
going to understand
what you're trying to do,
and a great example of this
are like navigation
apps, music-playing apps,
various exercise applications,
all of those scenarios,
if you're running a
foreground service
and the user sees
a notification,
it's going to make
sense to them.
You're going to be
really well aligned.
So in those scenarios,
please go do that.
In other ones where
you're like, I
don't know how to
explain this to a user,
then you should definitely
be considering Jobs
or just be considering
not running it
in the background at all.
So transitioning now, that
was the battery saving
and executions portion.
And now I'm going to
transition a little bit
to talk about location limits.
And the idea here was
to put some upper bounds
on what we're seeing
happening in the background
around geofencing,
polling, and others.
And it was causing really a
significant amount of drain.
And the reason is
location is power-hungry.
And there were really
no functional limits
on what an application
could do when
it's in the background
with respect to location.
And so it would end up with two
different types of scenarios.
And most of them, to be
honest, are accidental,
one being is that
applications are aggressively
requesting location.
And this could be
because they're
interested in where you are
or they have a particular use
case.
But the one that was really
sad was this idea of leaks,
is that if you're running
in the foreground,
say you're navigating,
you're going to have
a really high rate of query.
And when you go
to the background,
that high rate maybe
isn't necessary anymore.
And the intention of the
developer was to reduce it.
But for one reason or
another, similar memory leaks
or wake lock leaks, it's
still running full blast.
And that we saw a lot,
of a lot of applications
polling at every second
getting a location request.
And that's just going to
completely destroy battery.
And so those are the two areas
we're trying to target here.
So the idea now is
not to say that you
can't run in the background,
because we're still
enabling that.
But the idea is to space it
out, once every 30 minutes,
with a cycle of accuracy
of two to three minutes
within those 30-minute updates.
So you can think of it as
you have a 30-minute delay,
roughly, with then
an update accuracy
of two to three minutes
within that 30-minute cycle.
The same thing will
apply with Wi-Fi.
The API is a little
bit different.
We don't have that kind of
convenience for scheduling.
But the idea is
if you're banging
on the Wi-Fi scanning
query, you'll
keep getting the same results
if you're going too fast.
We won't actually do the query.
And so those are
the two strategies
that we've taken for
location and for Wi-Fi.
So just to highlight, there's
a number of options here
that are a lower
battery impacting
that you should be looking at.
One is batching, geofencing.
And in the complete
last case, again,
is to consider the
foreground service.
If you are using the
foreground service and the user
understands what's
happening-- that's really kind
of critical--
but if they understand what's
happening, that will then
enable them to
say, oh, OK, yeah,
you're running in
the background.
You're expensive.
I get it, moving on.
And you'll have
relaxed requirements
when you're in that mode.
So the other thing I wanted
to talk about a moment--
I know it feels like
all about battery,
and then suddenly, I'm
talking about Alert Window,
but I wanted to take
a moment to talk
about it-- is there's
a number of use cases
that this is coming up with.
And to be brutally
honest with you,
this was only intended
for what the name is--
System Alert Windows.
It was never really
consciously intended to be
used the way that it has been.
But we were in a simpler
world, an API one.
And it was left public.
And people have found really
amazing ideas and solutions
using this API.
And so we don't want
to get rid of it.
However, we do want to
try and put it on rails.
What we're really worried
about is many applications
rendering on top of each other,
conflicting with each other.
There's no attribution
of what applications
happen to be rendering
at any point in time.
And so the idea was that
can we add some layering?
Can we add some attribution
within the model?
And that's what we did with
the application overlay.
And so the idea here
is with an app overlay
is the user can
now manage what is
floating above their
application activity.
It's Z-ord, Z-ordered
properly unto themselves
and to system UI and to
the application below.
And it will automatically
show a foreground notification
in the notification
menus, so the user
is aware if there are multiple
applications simultaneously
using this feature.
This way, if they see it,
they're unhappy with it,
they can go to the application,
control the settings
if they want.
You should always make
sure your users are
aware of using this, because it
can be kind of surprising if it
doesn't happen.
And the other thing that we
changed was for targeting on O
is if you are now using
this new overlay type,
you will then sit
above the legacy views.
So this is maybe your
incentive to adopt
the new model, is once
you're using that, everybody
will be properly Z-ordered
in a kind of LRU fashion.
And then you'll sit
below system UI,
but above things like the
keyboard and other system UI
components.
So now I want to
transition a little bit
about talking about how
we're going to improve
the system with data.
And I don't mean
to blame anyone,
because that's not my intent.
But it's really a story
about applications
and that phones are amazing.
And you can do so many things
with this portable computing
device.
However, we have
resource scarcity, mostly
in the frame of battery.
And the question that
comes up, well, then,
how do we balance this?
And the big thing
that we realized,
and you might be
thinking at your seat,
like, yeah, no, duh, thanks.
But there really isn't great
tooling up until very recently
to help developers
understand their impact.
And when we reached out
even internally at Google,
we would find they didn't
realize they were doing it.
And so that kind of brought
around a number of thoughts
that I'll get into in a moment.
And the other one is this
kind of tragedy of the commons
in that you have so many
applications on your phone.
And if any of those applications
say, stick a wake lock,
you only need one to do it.
And the cost is now your CPU
is unable to go to sleep,
and you'll have a
very precipitous drain
on your battery over time.
And when you have hundreds
of apps and only one needs
to make a mistake,
you're pretty much
guaranteed to have a bad time.
And so what we
started looking at
is how can we get to a point
of sustaining performance,
introducing accurate
measurements for developers,
and bring online new dashboards?
So let's dig in a little
bit into what these are.
And there's a talk
on bad behaviors.
It was earlier in the day.
If you haven't seen it, please
go hop on YouTube and go
take a look at it.
It's very, very good.
The guys that presented
are right here in front
staring at me.
This is good.
Thank you.
But the big one here is we're
looking for egregious behavior
that we can all agree on.
And so a good example
of this is wake locks,
is if you ask a developer,
you are holding a wake lock
for six hours straight.
You were in the
foreground, and the user
wasn't interacting
with your application.
And pretty much
everybody says, yeah, I
shouldn't have been doing that.
And so the trick, though,
is there wasn't really
good instrumentation
to help you understand
that that was happening.
And that's where the Play
console is coming into its own
and bringing out these
features so you can now
see these type of situations
that are happening.
Other big one has
been really severely
janking frames,
so frozen frames.
Frames take over 700
milliseconds to run.
Also, really hard to figure
out where in your application
they're occurring.
And even if they're occurring,
and if they're occurring,
what devices they're
occurring on.
And then the last one was around
crash looping and a number
of other crash states.
The other one is we're also
looking at the OS side.
Not to say that
everything is about apps.
It's not.
We do have to bring a level
of sanity and attribution
to the operating system.
One good example of that
was the improvements
we made to the boot
time and really
looking hard at how
the OS is structured.
And the other one is
also going be starting
looking at I/O
throughput, how many scans
are happening in the background
in different parameters.
And all these things will
start coming out and being
available for you guys
over the coming years.
So just to give you
an example of this,
I have a selection
of Google Apps.
I have hidden the
names to protect
the innocent slash guilty.
But what I have put up
there is a hash line.
And the hash line is
effectively the threshold
that you're going
to see of when we
say an application has
crossed into the territory
of bad behavior.
So you can see the
majority of applications
in this cross-section.
And these are all
major Google Apps.
Most of them are quite good.
And there's a few outliers
that are having issues
where a wake lock is getting
stuck in their applications.
And you can see the
percentages here.
They look small.
But when you see these
numbers of like half
a percent here, 1% there,
those are just one app.
And as I mentioned
before, only one app
needs to make this mistake for
your entire device to suffer.
Multiply that by the 100 apps.
If you working out
the ratio, you're
going to have a bad time.
The next one here was talking
about foreground crashes
and helping our
developers understand
repeat crashes,
repeat offenders,
rapid crashing in a cycle.
We generally had
good instrumentation
to help developers understand
if you crash, but not necessary
the severity of repeated
crashes versus sporadic crashes.
Do I have a population of 5%
crashing really extremely,
or does it really spread
across a population 95%?
And the very last one here
is about frozen frames.
And you can see another
example of most applications
are actually doing pretty good.
And in this case, there was one
who was a little not as good.
And when we passed this
data along to the team,
they're like, crap, [CHUCKLES]
not their intent, obviously.
But it really makes
the experience
of the device not
really that fantastic,
especially their application.
And it makes the users
go on there, like,
is my device wrong?
Is the app bad?
What's happening?
So giving this information
back to the developers,
and they're able to start
remedying these problems
and solving them.
So the big thing
here is visibility.
And this is visibility
both for you guys
as well as for the
user on their device.
So in new developer
tools, we're also
doing a lot of outreach, both
internally and externally
with Biz Dev to reach out to
teams and inform them, hey,
do you know this is
happening on your apps?
And in many cases, we don't.
And it's an easy,
it's a quick fix,
and especially when it
comes to wake clocks.
It's usually a fairly
straightforward fix
once you know which wake lock
is the one that's been stuck.
And the last ones here is
battery settings in the Play
Store, and I'll talk a
little bit about that,
and then OEM dashboards,
because we also
want to get this data
over to OEM so they
can see what's going on.
And they can make sure that
devices are intrinsically good
and that you have a
strong base to work on,
that you're not seeing jank
because of the device freaking
out, but you're having
a good experience
and that you have the ability
to control your own destiny.
So Battery Menu
on here is about--
this is the new O Battery Menu.
And it was redesigned
with the idea
of being actionable for users.
We wanted to make sure that
if you go to this menu,
you don't go, OK, I see Google
Play Services, the Settings,
Android OS, and screen.
Like, what am I supposed
to think if I see this?
There's really nothing
actionable here.
And while it was
technically accurate,
it wasn't necessarily useful
to what you're trying to do,
is to understand
what applications are
impacting your battery life.
So this is how we
restructured it.
And we also included, though,
your foreground's interaction
with those applications.
And this is something that
happens really quite commonly.
And I'll give you just
a quick anecdote from--
internally, I had
a bug filed to me.
And it was about
Android O battery life.
It's horrible.
I don't make it past 3 o'clock.
What's going on?
And, you know, dig
into the bug report,
look at what's going on.
And what happened
on their device
was they were playing "Pokemon
Go" for two hours on Thursday
at 1:00 PM.
And my reply was like
that's pretty amazing
that you got this
much battery life out
of "Pokemon Go" on your phone.
Also, it was Thursday
at 1:00 PM, Googler.
But the thing was
that it took away
was they didn't realize
they played it that long.
And so that was
happening quite often.
You'd see an app be
high battery drain.
But you don't necessarily
recognize, oh,
it was because I used my phone
like an extra hour today.
And it's hard to
remember how long did
I really have the screen on.
And so that's how we
really structure battery
is to help inform you of how
long you're using the device,
how long you're using
different applications,
and so that you can make
this comparison of what
is happening in the apps.
We don't want to pass judgment
on an application being
good or bad.
It's not necessarily
a bad thing if an app
uses 20% of your battery.
If you were
live-streaming an event,
that's pretty decent, especially
if it was for an hour or two.
So we're not trying to say
intrinsically things are
bad if they're high.
But we do want to add
some visibility so
that a user can see
this is an app I
didn't engage with for days.
Why is it taking up
5% of my battery?
And then those
questions can start
happening on the users' part
and giving you guys feedback.
And then you can see the same
data in the Play console.
So this is where
I will transition
to talking a little
bit about the future
so you can kind of get an
idea of where we're going.
This is also my
suggestion to really
look at background limits,
to look at targeting O,
to transitioning away
from background services
to Jobs, Alarms, GCM, et cetera.
And the thing is we want to get
to this amazing battery life
that I started out with,
multi-day battery life.
And to do that, there's
a few things we're going
to have to change, if you will.
But I want to talk
about some principles.
One is we fundamentally
believe applications should be
able to run in the background.
We want much more
well-defined rules
about when applications
are able to run.
Today, you can see
a number of OEMs
taking strategies,
trying to solve
this problem independently.
And it becomes really
difficult for developers
to deal with that world
when you don't necessarily
know what the rules are.
So we want to get a
lot crisper there.
We also want users to better
understand battery impact.
You could argue my previous
statements about the Settings
menu where it's like,
what the user has
to do math in their head about
how much time that it used
or how much battery it used?
And I agree with you completely.
We want to get to a
better place where
it's much easier for a user to
understand what's happening.
And we want to then
enable a user who
says, I'm not OK with this,
and if the application doesn't
offer the control, to
give them another option
than uninstalling the
application, something other
than just the nuclear option.
And then the last
one is we really
want this idea of consistent
device performance,
that you shouldn't be worrying,
will my device make it
through the day today or not?
Will it be able to make it
till I get home on charger?
We want that to be
something reliable.
All these use cases that
we're doing on phones,
and all the properties
from Google,
and all the
properties that you're
making as app developers, you
can't really rely on this stuff
unless you know your
phone's going to be there.
And so that's really
the underpinnings
for this general strategy.
And so how do we get there?
So there's three big tiers
is we have to consider,
what is the API contract?
We don't want to break the
promises we make to you.
However, we do make a lot of
promises that we later regret.
And so an example of
this is a wake lock.
And if you were to generally
describe a wake lock,
you're saying, we've given the
application-- any application,
can tell the OS, stay
awake until I say
to go to sleep indefinitely.
And when you give
that level of control
and there's not really
a way to close the loop,
you end up with
varying battery life.
And so we have to
figure out, then,
what is the right promise
to make to a developer?
And what is the
range of that promise
that we should be giving.
So enable. the use
cases, but make sure
that the OS can be
responsive in the face
of adversity or
many applications
taking advantage of the
promise that's being made.
The other one is
that attribution
that I mentioned before
and the controls so
that the user can then take
advantage of this stuff.
And together, the
three of these things
should give us a much
a better structure.
And so all of this
is, again, like you
see this little exciting badge
of a pending review on there.
These are really just
ideas to articulate
how we're approaching
the problem, because we
know it's a big change.
And so we're trying to broadcast
this change really early so you
can take advantage of it.
You can start moving
over to background limits
and targeting O now so
that you're not going
to have a bad time later on.
And so some of
these things is we
need to look at more limits
on background scanning.
We have to adjust the
limits that we're doing.
We haven't really gotten
around to Bluetooth yet.
We're also looking
at applications
listening to other
events on the device
and whether those things
should be happening or not.
The big one here
is deferring work.
We want the OS to
have more flexibility
to have discretion
about when jobs run.
When it's all services-based,
the OS has really no control.
If a single large
install-based application
makes a unilateral decision to
increase its wake lock time,
the OS today and the user
is powerless to do anything
about it.
And so that's why we're looking
to make these transitions.
And the balance
should be, now, users
are more in the
driver's seat about what
features the
application's giving
and whether the user finds
value in those features running
in the background, and then
they can articulate that.
The defaults for all
of these things is on.
And the model you
can roughly think
about it as long as you're
cool, the OS will be cool.
And everybody will be
cool, and it's great.
And if in this scenario,
though, applications
start getting aggressive,
batteries starts getting high,
scanning rates start
getting higher,
we may start informing the user,
hey, this stuff's kind of heavy
on your battery.
Do you want it to run
in the background?
And then they can articulate
take back to the OS.
And then we can begin having
a control surface for how we
manage individual applications.
And so then the user
can say, these 10
apps I care about a lot.
These other apps, not so much.
We're not suggesting
that we need
to have a micro-managing menu.
That's not the desire.
But using things like
how users are interacting
with the application, how
often are interacting with GCM
messages when the
application gets woken up,
how often do they interact
with notifications,
these are all great
signals to inform
how the OS should dole out
its limited resources, namely
battery.
And the last one is we have to
beef up the idea of foreground
service and figure out how
does that as an API surface
and how does that as
a UI construct not
turn into all the
applications rushing
to the exits of
foreground service.
And then we're back
in the same mess
that we are now with no
control surface again.
We want to find a balance so
that applications can generally
do everything they need
and that in the extremes,
the user's able to
articulate approval
for these extreme situations.
And we're hoping
that that's going
to result in a much more stable,
much more reliable device
in the long run.
And so hopefully, that
gives you a bit of insight
about how we're approaching
Android health and mostly
the battery life and
resource contention.
Oh, I forgot a slide.
But the idea here in the last
one was attribution and value.
And so we want to really
make that identified.
And I already talked
about the point,
so I won't bore
you repeating it.
And thank you very
much for your time.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]